[Music]
ah
but first word from our sponsor lord's
mobile
this is my third collaboration with lord
smallmouth
but it's also lords mobile's fifth
anniversary
happy birthday lord mobile happy
birthday let me ask you something do you
like gaming
do you like money download lord's mobile
because lords mobile is giving away 50
to celebrate their fifth anniversary but
they're not just giving away cash to you
guys
they're also giving away fifty thousand
dollars to the make a wish foundation
which is an amazing charity
i supported it for years and if i do
reference it in a rap song that may have
already been uploaded or not
just know that that was a joke just to
record
it it is amazing charity it helps kids
with
different illnesses and sufferings to
help them make their dreams come true
how do i describe lord's mobile for
those who don't know basically
if sun tzu was still alive the master
strategist
of all time the chinese warlord the
undefeated master
if he was alive today he'd be sitting on
his ass playing lord's mobile you bet
your
butts and his tomb wow arrow
formation that's so epic quote son two
because launch mobile is the best
strategy game
where you can develop your own kingdom
recruit massive armies
and do arrow formations and if you're
feeling extra viking
like me you can burn their castles and
ransom their leaders now that's a gamer
move
but the game is not only about brutal
fights you can also make friends
maybe even game or girlfriend best case
scenario
i downloaded lord's mobile and i met my
future wife
and won a bunch of money and supported
charity wow
there's a guild supporting you in every
war that you go through for the 50 000
giveaway there's two ways to win the top
15 players in the might rank section
can win a thousand dollar cash each but
they can also win
the most prized possession of all a
lord's mobile with a pewdiepie signature
bam that's gotta be worth at least um
five
anyway you increase your mind by
leveling up your kingdom
and just do what gamers do but you can
also spin
lucky will to win a thousand dollar cash
and merge with autograph spin wheel the
epic gamer
they both work every download would
contribute to the make-a-wish foundation
as well so
it's for a good cause check it out link
it's in the description
you guys know what to do thank you lords
mobile for sponsoring this video
now let's get on with it good morning
gamers
i got a [ __ ] headache and a nosebleed
but let's do this today we're checking
out tlc
america's cheapest family this isn't
america's cheapest family this is
america's dumbest life hacks
okay i'm looking forward to seeing this
now wait wait wait
wait the dad is the type of
hell no all right
let's watch this i'm ready
sorry i usually watch them two times
being here here we go i'll slow it down
for you
for your slow brained individuals yeah
my brain's so fat no
i can see ew in the plate
and also the dumb comment from the kid i
don't even know where to begin with it
breaking that down
no you can't those are dirty and you
know it
look how dirty the brush is
i'm melanie o'brien and i'm shawn
o'brien and we're america's cheapest
family
i mean they're not self-proclaimed
america's cheapest family you know tlc
producers are
like all right it would be really cool
if you guys call yourself like
cheapest family that'd be that'd be
insane if you could just
like but anyway i'm curious well may
well
all right do they do they pass the test
it rains
in the summertime when the kids are
playing outside in the pool
we can utilize that afterwards to help
i'm sorry but that
you call that a pool i respect that
to help clean our dishes we save money
on the water bill we save money on the
electric bill
i don't get it just reuse the water
right when you do the dishes you just
put a little bit of water you close the
tap and then
you use the other and like you don't use
that much water
that's that's a pretty big house like do
they really need to
all right whatever shawn and i agree
that if we don't have to buy anything
new
then we won't and we'll make use with
what we have
that's our lifestyle that's our way i
mean
yeah that's that's fine oh my god her
pan doesn't have a handle on it
that is so annoying how do they cook
couldn't they just fix that somehow
the handles broke off yeah instead of
going out
and buying brand new pots and pans we
didn't fix it
what did you do
that is a bridge he didn't make that
wrench
[Laughter]
what do you mean he made a wrench you're
telling me he can make this wrench but
he can't make a handle for his
[ __ ] duct tape protects my hands from
burning
all right oh so he put duct tape on the
handle
on a bridge and he said look i made you
this wrench
it's been more than ten years since sean
and melanie have made any significant
improvements to their home a sacrifice
they claim has saved them
over 30 thousand dollars
this is where we spend most of our time
in the living room um
as you can see we've got very sparse
furniture
living room furniture can cost up to 10
000 depending on what kind you're buying
and ours cost
maybe 50 bucks
why even have any living room furniture
if that's what you're gonna go with
what i would rather have an empty room
than my room looking like that that's
all i'm gonna say
sit on the floor floor again come on
ours cost
maybe 50 bucks a few months ago our
shower head broke
and sean came up with a great way to fix
it
what the [ __ ] is that what is that
there's no hole what oh
let me guess let me guess he put duct
tape on around it is that what he did
he just made a new one and
now we have a brand new shower head
this wow wow
some people might think our behavior is
over the top
uh but excuse me you're wasting all the
water in the bottle
huh you better be reusing that mr and
mrs frugal come on
for the past several years see they're
sitting on the floor anyway
they're not even using that dirt pile
whatever that is ew
moving into a larger space but selling
their current home would require them to
make renovations they've avoided for the
past
decade our realtor is going to come over
and
give us what a guy what a guy that's
your realtor
okay give us an assessment and evaluate
what we need to do
before we actually put our house in the
market
here's the yard how about this
empty all the [ __ ] you don't have much
anyway
our fence is a little piecemealed
together so i just replaced the boards
as they come leans a little but it's
dirty
you're gonna have to repaint the fence
i mean if not replaced it's uh how much
is we looking to replace
around 1800 bucks just paint it bro
just paint it you don't have oh my god
it brings
character to the neighborhood and the
kickball it brings character to the
neighbor is that what you think
is that really what you think just paint
it
just paint it you just have to paint it
oh my god this guy's the worst
i get i get i understand
completely wanting to fix things on your
own and not call
someone to get in and do it but at least
try a little bit man
what is this it's in the right place
that is so sloppy dude and you know it
number one
no furniture this won't work you've got
to stay to certain
stage how no you don't have to stage it
just
just remove all your crap please well
a bean bag an ottoman i mean you've got
to have
furniture here i love this they tried so
long look at that mom's face she's
terrified
they so you're telling me
we haven't had furniture for a decade
and now we have to get it before we move
out
we could have got just fire in a journal
along if i if i bought a house i'd
rather see it empty than staged with a
bunch of tit furniture
i've seen houses online that don't have
any furniture yes
yes not always the majority of them are
new
well i was so white so what mr realtor
huh
you got crazy glasses have a thing none
of these homes that are selling
has carpet like this the stains
i i honestly don't feel like a buyer
would even put an offer in
with carpet like this how nasty is that
carpet i want to see it close up
please i need to see that carpet yeah i
don't get it
in uk everyone puts carpet and it's
disgusting
it's actually disgusting putting my own
floor in my place whatever
this type show a photo it looks sick
hey they're driving volvo base
no don't get another carpet they're so
ugly
here we'd probably be looking at about a
four thousand dollar buck
what i thought carpe was cheap i thought
that was the whole point
bro just put in vinyl floor my brother
come on
it'll look good i'll come over and help
you all right do you still have the
floor
what literally is the cheapest
that you could help me out with eighteen
hundred to two thousand dollars
i mean all right so what i'm really just
kind of looking for
but you guys have a budget of thirty
thousand now right because you saved all
that money right
two sections uh you know a burnt stain
here
maybe some you just want to change
sections of the carpet yeah
is it unheard of to patch up
carpet i mean
it really is unheard of i've never heard
such thing i definitely don't want it to
be
horrific but is there a way to get
something i mean it's not a bad idea
right if they're just trying to sell the
place and don't want to spend a lot of
money you could
yeah you could just change parts of it i
don't know why he's acting so offended
about it
it's an ugly ass carpet anyway
your carpet sucked dude okay you don't
want to buy all the carpet
i
that would definitely be a first we can
take a look okay
let's take a look and see what we can
work out sure oh you know i've seen all
types of customers over the years in our
business
i've never had anyone ask me for samples
all right here's our sample room
you guys can take a look around oh my
god i'm but but
wait wait a minute wait a minute you
have to get the same carpet right you
can't you're not going to patch it up
like you patched up the fence right
[Laughter]
please tell me you're not oh god
i want to find something that matches as
best as possible
ah yeah that one on top is better
see if you can find more like that no no
no no you can't do better you have to
have the same one if you're pulling this
[ __ ]
you have to have the same one oh
okay they got it i think you got it huh
this
that no one that one oh
this is gonna be the closest we'll make
it match uh
guys i don't know how about uh how about
20.
we'll do 20 okay i appreciate it thank
you
all right i have a bag well played
today the man just saved himself a
thousand eight hundred i i don't i don't
know why i can't hate on that i think
it's when they
they try to be frugal with these small
things that are just disgusting
that's when it kind of bothers me but it
remains to be seen how this looks like
to be fair
advised to replace the carpeting and
refurnish their living room before
showing their home
with the help of their neighbor they're
hoping to stage the area
for free could borrow your furniture
for the open house you know how our
living room looks now and you're so
close by and you've got such great
furniture we just really love to use
yours if you don't mind
like what are you thinking um yeah i was
thinking the couch
the nice coffee table that's not even
better come on i mean the coffee tables
all right i guess all right all right
all right oh i'm trusting in you
thank you okay um mark's gonna kill me
no more you're left
got it you can stop for a minute of
course rather than hire professionals to
replace their entire carpet
shawn tacks down their two all right
let's see
[Applause]
okay
just keep the [ __ ] stain dude just
keep the stain
what is that [ __ ] oh
god what have you done that is terrible
that is terrible oh
no it even has the branding thing on it
it's a sample
it shows the brand on it oh my god
why did you totally different color
i mean you did it great you did a great
job but it just doesn't match
right we knew it wasn't 100 match
that's not even close to 50. wouldn't it
be easier to just
yeah just put a coffee table over the
stain or something i don't know
is that legal when we first walked in i
noticed
little details oh they noticed the
carpet
i can't believe it i can't believe they
noticed the carpet unbelievable
if those are the things that are showing
what what are we not seeing
yeah people who are different are always
going to be
called because i'd do it a different way
than somebody else you're gonna do this
every time you go to the bathroom oh
look it's another player he made that
plier
he created that it's a toilet plunger
he made it no
we're in texas in dallas we're in a good
market there's gonna be somebody out
there that's gonna
look it and say i like it dude he looks
sleepy all the time dude
he's so busy doing these diy hacks
you're not gonna sell that house or at
least you're not gonna get a good offer
on it
sometimes you have to spend money to
make money just sometimes
they honestly sound like they're
covering up a murder
yeah right you go to a carpet store hey
can we just replace one
section of the carpet
it's just red wine he walks around with
a piggy bank
i'm jordan page and i'm the ultimate
cheapskate housewife
and remember you need to eat all your
cheerios or next time you only get 12.
wait oh this is sad
the kid doesn't even get milk you can't
have cereal like that
she rations her kids waffles so she can
buy heels and dresses
yeah what is happening here jordan has
found some of the biggest savings in the
bathroom
cutting her family's use of toilet paper
from 300 rolls a year
to only 40. the way to stretch your
money is to make
everything count see three should we do
three okay let's rip
one how much do you think daddy should
use
um four jordan always harps on me for
using too much toilet paper hey let's
try it oh my god
you got a wipe you got a white you got a
wife you got a white
i don't want to live like they [ __ ] your
highlights i'm wiping my ass
but she wants to at least try and make
that
roll go farther my mane just go to
[ __ ]
starbucks and grab a bunch of totally i
don't know
i'm going to walk around with a sweaty
ass just because you want to
get a new top what the [ __ ] is this i am
offended by this
met jordan no one no one decides how
many wipes i have
that's a massive [ __ ] house dude hey
chris how's it going
i was actually wondering if you guys had
any leftovers or any food
no [ __ ] off [ __ ] it's my food and my
toilet you're not getting my toilet
paper you understand
oh god i i i hate this i don't know why
why do i hate this so much
it's like you can't know if someone
actually needs your help
or if they're just trying to save money
from you
that's what's annoying about this like
if someone came to my house and asked
hey i i
i need some food food do you have
anything of course
of course but if there's bait it rolls
up no
no so this is what i like to call an
end loaf oh a lot of bread
and a lot of people don't like to eat
the heels of bread but
bubba likes it my kids love it and it's
still good so
after a while it makes an entire loaf
worth doesn't that bread go old
what oh dashboard with the car
temperature at 160 degrees
she's finished baking for free ew look
at all the oil that's
running on thinking that's led jordan to
her newest
and perhaps most extreme penny pinching
plan i mean yeah that
seemed to work what the [ __ ] no no hear
me out
we could raise a pig and then get
a pig out of it you can pay upwards of
per dozen for eggs you pay 10 bucks for
a chicken
six chickens later you're getting a half
dozen eggs a day
can't you just start growing some
vegetables at least not start with the
farm
i realize this is like a an addiction
for these people they're addicted
it's not it doesn't become about saving
money anymore it's about like
yeah i beat the system it's like this uh
it's this thing right where they they
get this gratification like oh i saved
the buck oh that feels good
oh nice and then they want to keep doing
that and keep doing that and keep doing
that and find different ways to do it it
just becomes
ridiculous and it's like do you even
need to save the money at this point
you can raise your own animals for a
fraction of the cost as it would be to
buy
an organic so you're gonna kill that pig
when he grows up that's just cold man
i don't know how i feel about this
imagine having kids and then they bring
in this new animal
and they love it and then you have to
make them eat it
how are they gonna kill it how are they
going to make sure they can does she
had god all right maybe they did their
research
and the pig's okay back at the farm he's
doing just fine
fatten them up
i want chickens
[Laughter]
[Music]
shelter i mean nothing will reach her
savings goal
in two months the chickens they would be
laying half a dozen eggs a day
the goats saving 12 bucks a day on a
gallon of milk would be pretty awesome
are we cut out to be backyard farmers i
don't know but the number's out
is she is she counting the cost of
maintaining these and the time that it
will take
all right that is cheap skates
of america i feel bad i feel bad for the
kids not gonna lie
thank you for watching this video i'd
never feel bad for kids because tomorrow
cocomell and diss track be ready
profess subscribe epic what just
happened
sir sir i think we hit bedrock
what does that mean it means you can't
go
any deeper good oh
why is that sir
there's nothing deeper than me